hello I'm max fans what's your name Lara  surname Croft I'm Alyssa vikander one of  my favorite characters growing up was  Lara Croft and I've been lucky enough to  play her in the new movie Tomb Raider  para you could make up where your  father's left off  I found something a tomb called the  mother of death if Trinity succeeds our  world is in danger what I love about  Lara is that she is incredibly smart  pregnant and fiercely independent in  this adventure she discovers she is  capable of surviving anything death  isn't an adventure  to see what Lara's up against and  discover the secrets of tomb raider book  your tickets now  [Music]